minutes after this video was taken
Natasha
ednan la pérouse suffered an allergic
reaction to a Preta Mons a sandwich
she'd eaten for breakfast
her brother Alex was at home in London I
got a phone call from my dad saying that
Natasha was going to die in a few
minutes and I had to give my last
goodbyes through the phone to her I said
I love you so much - you've been a great
sister to me thank you for everything I
love you
and then my dad hung up I had this pain
in my chest that at the time when he
said that she was gonna die it was this
pain that I've never felt it was
excruciating
Natasha's death led her family to call
for a change in the law in almost three
years on they have won their battle it
is a phenomenal news for it not just for
us but for all the people in this
country who have severe food allergies
so you know millions of people it's a
real fantastic result it's there to save
lives ultimately it's so difficult to
navigate your life with food allergies
and this creates a situation where
labels can be trusted currently food
prepared in store does not have to carry
an allergy warning on the packaging
so while Natasha had no idea she was
eating sesame Preta Monge was not
breaking the law but from 2021
manufacturers will have to list full
ingredients on all prepackaged food a
Research Foundation has been set up in
Natasha's name to try and prevent other
families being devastated it has a
high-profile supporter in the Duchess of
York who first met Tanya in the deme as
they flew their daughter's body home a
patron of the foundation she's
challenged the food industry to drop
objections to the new law when they see
Tanya Nadeem and the pain and how they
override the pain with courage to make a
change 4 million
of families and communities that now are
being listened to because of allergies I
think that they they they can lead by
example Natasha would have turned 18
this year her family hopes some good may
come from her death
Paul Kelso Sky News